good morning believe nation today's
message is do what you care about over
to you Neil Gaiman awake baby go right
things people want to read right things
you care about um don't you know i get i
get puzzled and lost when people start
asking me questions about what they
should be writing for the market
whatever there is no market nobody
there's nobody in the whole world of
marketing ever would have woken up one
day and said a series of unfortunate
events is exactly what the world needs
us you know nobody would have turned
around and gone are your market niche is
do a sort of reply to kiplings the
jungle book and set it in the graveyard
that's not you know things like that
happen because somebody wants to tell a
story and because you have an idea
because you think you can tell that
story better than anybody else I've said
this a lot in the channel but the most
important business principle to
understand is that if you want to have
success in the business contact it's
about providing value right you want to
make money you want to have an impact
you want to create an amazing company
it's going to come from providing value
the more value provide the more success
you'll have and one of the easiest ways
to provide value to others is to first
provide value to yourself by creating
something that you love and that you
care about and to have your opinion be
the proxy to create products and
services for other people if you create
something that you love that you are
personally attached to your creative run
the need that you have and then you
share it with the world chances are
there's a lot of people who also have
that same need desire passion it may not
be something you create that everybody
consumes and everybody loves but if you
love something if you watch something
create something make something and you
love it and it makes you come alive and
it gets you hot
your heart beating and you are proud of
what you just made is something that you
want to show your grandkids you can't
wait to tell people about like if you
have that kind of deep attachment to the
stuff that you're creating then I
guarantee you there will be other people
in this world who will also love it and
they will pay you for it and you will
have success as an entrepreneur as a
creator because you made that and so you
should let your opinion your emotion be
the guide to help you create those
products and services even now for my
channel right we've got six people who
work on my youtube channel last night I
was working all night on the top 10
videos the research that goes behind
them I cut half of the videos that came
through for the Chris Rock top 10 that
we're working on because the videos were
ok but they didn't move me like I didn't
watch that clip whether it was a 20
second clip or four minute clip I didn't
watch it and want to make any kind of
improvement to my life for business I
didn't watch that clip and it made me
think it was just an okay clip it wasn't
terrible wasn't boring it just didn't
make me think that doesn't belong in my
top 10 series like I want to include
clips that make me come alive that make
me question myself that helped me grow I
want to create something that I'm proud
of that I love that moves me and then I
know when I do that you guys will enjoy
to maybe not everybody you know maybe
what resonates with me doesn't resonate
with every single one of you but on the
whole when I spend the time to make sure
that I love the product is being created
more of you love it as well and I made
these videos the start of the series the
genesis of the top 10 series and
interests some believe life and all of
this was not because you guys requested
it wasn't because people were telling me
you need to do this because I needed it
because I wanted it I had to create it i
had to birth it and now you guys help
with the picking up hey who do we do
next and still i'll use judgment like
there's some people that we just don't
have enough content on to be able to
create a meaningful top 10 video and
that might generate millions of views if
we did this person but there's just not
enough good stuff and so we don't do it
and you know my channel my business at
the point
or I could I could mail it in for a
little bit right we have enough of an
audience I could put out just okay top
10 videos you guys would still watch
them for a little bit of time we could
just smash together some interviews pull
out some random points and put them
together but that wouldn't that's not
sustainable right and it's not enjoyable
either and it's not the value that I'm
trying to have it doesn't make me feel
good as a human being and it's not
having an impact on your life and your
business and so the most important basic
business principle is to be successful
as an entrepreneur you need to provide
value and quite often the best way to do
it is to create something that provides
value for yourself because if you can do
that there's tons of other people who
have the same problem same passion say
need and by you solving it for them they
will pay you for it so the question
today today is I'm curious what you care
about most in your business you know
there are some things that you could
give away that you're doing now because
you kind of have to but what do you care
about most you don't want anybody to
touch because it has to have your stamp
of approval on it that will knock the
world until you have seen it and loved
it what is that piece in your business
that you will never let go because you
care so deeply about it leave me in the
comments below super curious to find out
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events vessel oh wait
expresso give me go
you